good
morning welcome to this joint overview
and scrutiny committee I am councelor
Mary McLaren and I'm chairing the
meeting today may I first remind you of
some domestic
Arrangements if you attending the
meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
please ensure your mobile phones and
laptops are on
silent actually can I just add to that
if you've your laptops in front of the
microphone can you make sure that you
you've got full access to the
microphones thank
you additionally we will be using EV
voting for this meeting on the mo.gov
app the council members of the public
and the Press May record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded if you are intending to do so
please inform the committee
clerk if you hear the fire alarm leave
the building immediately via a fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
which is in it switch Town Football
ground follow the signs directing you to
the fire exit at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium which is the
ground floor area and
walkways if you are in the atrium and at
the time of the alarm follow the signs
to the nearest fire
exit use the stairs not the lifs do not
enter the building until told it is safe
to do
so we will now proceed to the formal
part of our meeting uh I would like to
work welcome the following people we
have in
attendance uh this morning we've got
counselor Jessica who is Cabinet member
for
housing and um we've then got the
following of we we're waiting for uh
another counselor Cabinet member but
hasn't arrived yet because of traffic
problems so I'd like to welcome the
officers uh Amma anti aboa corporate
manager for Housing Solutions Victoria
Bond assistant manager for Housing
Solutions Rebecca Ward housing in
strategy and policy officer Susanna
Farah team manager for homelessness
Sarah olders team manager for early
intervention Mula mopo team manager
temporary accommodation and Stephanie
Lloyd team manager Central suffk
Latins thank you and it helping us today
as our lead officer for overview and
scrutiny we have Alysia Norman
can I move to the agenda please thank
you apologies for absons and
substitutions thank you chair we have
apologies this morning from councilor R
uh but we have no substitutes thank you
chair thank
you item two to receive Declarations of
peun pecun other registerable or non-reg
interests by members
thank you um chair um I am am a private
landlord so um I'd like to declare that
as an
interest thank you chair and my wife is
a private landlord and I'm also a
trustee of The Stone Market relief trust
which may inadvertently get referred to
later on
of a company that is a private
landlord as is my
wife can we go to item
three J
2326 to confirm the minutes of the joint
meeting held on the 23rd of
October 2023 now I must advise members
that you are referring to the minutes as
detailed in the table papers not with
those that was first issued with the
agenda so are there any points regarding
the accuracy of the
minutes
no could I have a proposal please
councelor Jameson and a
second counselor Smith thank you very
much the lead officer will cont conduct
the electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in progress on M
go
thank you chair that is nine votes for
and one abstention so those are
carried so the minutes of the joint
meeting on the 23rd of October have been
confirmed item four to receive notific
ation of petitions in accordance with
the council's petition scheme none
received
chair uh item five questions by the
public none received and item six
questions by counselors none received
shair thank you so we've now uh come to
item seven which is j23 stroke 27
homelessness reduction and R sleeping
strategy
2024 I would like to invite councelor
Carter to introduce the report to the
committee thank you councelor
Carter thank you um good morning
everyone as the portfolio holder
responsible for housing it is my
privilege to introduce the homelessness
prevention and rough sleeping strategy
for 2024
2029 this strategy is a testament to our
commitment to ensure that homelessness
and rough sleeping are a rare brief and
non reoccurring events in our community
the strategy is grounded in the
principles of prevention and early
Upstream Intervention which are Central
to our vision and operational ethos the
homelessness Act of 2002 mandates all
housing authorities to review
homelessness within their jurisdictions
and develop a strategy based on the
findings our previous strategy for 2019
2024 has undergone a thorough review and
the insights gained Have Been
instrumental in shaping this new
strategy
the comprehensive Babor and midu
homeless homelessness review 2023 which
serves as a foundation for this
strategy homelessness is a complex issue
that extends beyond the stereotypical
image of a rough sleeper it encompasses
individuals and families living in
insecure unsuitable or unaffordable
housing and those who are forced to
leave their homes often through no fault
of their own this strategy aims to
destigmatize homelessness and empower
residents to help seek at the earliest
opportunity it also focuses on early
Upstream intervent intervention to
prevent homelessness or proactivity our
vision is clear to make rough sleeping
rare brief and non- reoccurring to
prevent homelessness through the early
and Upstream intervention and to achieve
this we will focus on early prevention
working closely with those who have who
have lived experiences and develop a
multi- agency approach to support people
in rebuilding buing their lives our
priorities include early intervention
making rough sleep making rough sleeping
rare ensuring the health and well-being
of households in temporary accommodation
and mitigating the impacts of the cost
of
living we have already made significant
strides in addressing homelessness such
as developing and online advice service
housing aid for easy access to housing
options established an early
intervention team to focus on targeted
early and Upstream intervention
delivered domestic abuse Champion
training to raise awareness and provide
support for those affected by domestic
abuse going forward we will resource the
early interventions team adequately to
maximize opportunities for preventing
homelessness establish protocols with
other agencies for multi- agency
approach to homelessness prevention
consider the needs of our rural
communities and explore the viability of
a mobile customer access point for
Housing Services and work towards
obtaining domestic abuse housing
Alliance accreditation in conclusion
this strategy is not just a document it
is a commitment a commitment to our
residents that we will not rest until
homelessness and rough sleeping are rare
and brief in our districts it is an
ambitious goal but with the strategies
we have in place and Partnerships we are
building it is with on our reach um and
if I can just take this moment just to
thank the officers who have put this
together and made it all possible thank
you
thank you councelor
Carter I'll just wait for councelor pear
to thank
you um members can now ask
questions who was going to uh start the
questions they have a presentation oh
sorry sorry that wasn't on the agenda
Sor no U I understand now what you said
to me
earlier I will ask the corporate manager
to give us a presentation that would be
really
helpful thank you no Rebecca's going to
give the presentation but off the back
of what counsil Carter has said it's
just we want I suppose we're just quite
passionate about homelessness within our
service and resolving it so we're hoping
that this strategy Builds on that and we
definitely hope that we will make some
real headways in the next five years so
with Rebecca's presentation she will
go I'm
sorry
yeah sorry um Rebecca is going to go
through all the priorities and so that
and at each point we'll ask questions
after each section each priority so we
can take the questions
then if that's
okay yeah thank
you hi everybody um I'm Rebecca Ward
housing strategy and policy officer and
I'm responsible for the monitoring of
the homelessness
strategy I've been involved throughout
this year in the development of this new
draft homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy this presentation
seeks to provide you with some
background information and context
before looking at each of the five
priorities in turn setting out what has
been achieved already and what officers
will be focusing on next to contribute
towards achieving the vision and aims of
this new
strategy okay so to start with some
background information it just is it is
a statutary requirement for local
authorities to carry out a homelessness
review and to publish a strategy based
based on the findings of that
review all local authorities are
required to publish a homelessness
strategy once every 5
years the previous joint homelessness
strategy was adopted following
endorsement by both councils in March
2019 and covered the period to
2024 a comprehensive homelessness review
was carried out earlier this year the
purpose of the review was to establish
the extent of homelessness in the
district a set its likely extent in the
future
identify what is currently being done
and by whom identify what level of
resources are available to prevent and
Tackle homelessness and to inform future
homelessness services with the aim of
preventing and managing
homelessness a survey of stakeholders
and partners was also conducted and the
findings fed into both the homelessness
review and into the development of this
new
strategy the draft strategy will be
consulted on for a period of six weeks
from Monday the 4th of December to
Sunday the 14th of
January during this time there'll be an
open survey this will be available to
any Resident or interested party but
will also be targeted to stakeholders
Partners members and those with lived
experience of
homelessness the draft strategy will
also be presented to the tenants board
and there'll be a number of all member
briefing
sessions okay so moving on to the draft
joint strategy following the findings
and outcomes of the homelessness review
a vision and five priorities were
identified and developed our vision is
that rough sleeping is rare brief and
non-recurring and that homelessness is
routinely prevented through early and
Upstream
intervention five priority areas of
focus have been identified to contribute
to achieving this Vision these
priorities are early Upstream
preventional
intervention making rough sleeping rare
brief for
non-recurring ensuring the health and
well-being needs of households are met
whilst in temporary
accommodation expanding and future
proofing the role and remit of central
suff lettings to continue to improve
access to the private rented
sector and mitigating mitigating against
the impact of the cost of living we will
look at these priorities in turn and in
more detail
shortly before we move on to look at the
priorities individually just some
information about how the strategy is
structured the strategy is reported and
underpinned by a delivery plan the draft
version is in your papers at present it
shows only the action and the action
owners this is a person who will be
responsible for progress and providing
updates as you can see from this slide
there are multiple teams within the
councils that will be contributing to
the achievement of the vision and aims
of this
strategy further details such as Target
date status and what success looks like
will be added prior to proposed adoption
of the strategy following consultation
and evaluation and Incorporation
operation of feedback in March of next
year the strategy will then be monitored
on a quarterly basis and will be
reviewed annually by overview and
scrutiny as part of the annual review of
The Joint homes and housing
strategy okay so moving on to the
priorities of this strategy the first
priority area is early Upstream
prevention and intervention this
strategy seeks to ensure that both PR
Von and early Upstream intervention are
at the center of our
service the prevention of homelessness
is mutually beneficial for both the
councils and
households early intervention strategies
aim to support individuals and families
in retaining housing or swiftly
transitioning to Safe accommodation with
necessary
support this approach sign significantly
reduces relief Duty and main duty
decisions and enables Housing Solutions
officers to concentrate on relieving
homelessness for already home
households our focus is on creating
customized Pathways with wraparound
support to ensure sustained Tendencies
for every client
group in terms of achievements we have
already created and established the
early intervention team to focus on
targeted early and Upstream intervention
there is now one team manager and four
housing solution officers focusing slow
solely on early intervention
work we've developed and implemented a
comprehensive online advice service for
clients to Access housing options advice
housing aid we have sustained tencies
and prevented homelessness by ensuring
tencies remain financially viable via
team of financial inclusion
officers we have delivered domestic
abuse Champion training this has been
led by the Housing Solutions domestic
abuse Link Worker there are now domestic
abuse Champions located across Babor and
mid stuffer District councils who have
received domestic abuse awareness
training to develop knowledge on asking
responding supporting and signposting
people affected by domestic
abuse we've also established the
household support fund to work with
households prior to the 56 days when
under legislation they're threatened
with
homelessness we've also focused on early
intervention work to significantly
reduce the time officers are spending
making decisions on homelessness
applications as a result there's only
been two intentional decisions made
since April
2023 um in the next year we'll be
working on setting up protocols with
other agencies to formalize early
intervention multi- agency arrangements
with probation prisons hospitals adult
care services and children's and young
people services to work collaboratively
and prevent homelessness for our most
vulnerable
residents we'll be establishing early
intervention hubs in our districts for
face-to-face meetings to facilitate more
effective communication help to build
strong relationships and increase
engagement
we'll be working towards obtaining
domestic abuse housing Alliance
accreditation to raise awareness of a
domestic abuse to enable a proactive not
reactive service focusing on households
remaining in accommodation or working
towards more managed
moves and we'll be creating a FastTrack
referral system to Central suffer
lettings to ensure cases where
homelessness can be prevented quickly
through the use of the rent guarantee
scheme are prioritized and dealt with
effectively we'll also be working on
establishing team processes and links to
other in-house teams especially the
financial inclusion team and Central
suff lettings to complement Service
delivery and we'll be considering the
viability of a mobile customer access
point for Housing Services to consider
how we can best serve the needs of our
rural
communities thank
you any other members of the team going
to present
I think we're going to say any questions
from anybody before we move on about
about early Upstream prevention and
intervention thank you chair well you've
mentioned um working towards obtaining
domestic abuse housing Alliance
accreditation and the work that's
involved in that and that does seem to
be quite considerable work my query
would be um on page 100 when uh when
you're talking about that um at the end
it said sign up to the accreditation
would need to be agreed to and supported
at a senior leadership level um so
obviously that requires a commitment
from the senior leadership but does not
does that not perhaps this is a question
for one the portfolio holders does that
not require then a commitment from uh
each of the local authorities to
actually achieving that because I think
it's a very good idea that we do achieve
it but recognize the work that's
involved and the resources that would be
be required so perhaps I could have an
answer from one of them thank youe go
ahead I'm quite happy to answer that
question um we've recently taken and
done a presentation to SLT about the dah
accreditation and what's going to be
required and resources required we're
currently going to the good start
project board on Tuesday this week to
look at that so hopefully there is
commitment there is a broad consensus of
this is something that we would like to
do as an organization obviously
permitting on resources so that's what
we're doing at the moment is looking at
that aspect of
it councelor
Carter thank you you just mentioned the
believe regards a mobile hub um for
viability would this be a physically
moving vehicle of some sort are you
talking about hiring rooms in certain
facilities for somebody to go into I'm
just wondering if it's going to be a
physically moving like a vehicle um have
you thought about the access into the
vehicle as some rough sleepers or
individuals may have M mobility issues
may not be able to access up so just
wearing in
that I
think I think for me is the real because
we're such have such rural locations and
transport tends to be issue it's really
about getting offices to Residents about
rather than expecting people to try and
come to us or locations that we already
have existing we want to be looking at
creative ways in terms of can we get
some sort of maybe a prevention bus or
an advice bus which takes the service to
the residents in their locality for a
sense so I don't think we're necessarily
en visiting having people being on the
bus it's more about getting the services
out to them more than others so that's
what we're looking at doing in that
sense
any more questions from the
committee um because we're going to take
each stage and go with questions each
time so I can I ask any of the
counselors that in the room have got
questions
no councelor malvy
thank um but of the 57
cases um in babber how many were
domestic
abuse I can have a little look and I'll
break it down and I'll let you know
probably at the end of this session is
that okay fine super thank
you thank you anybody else on the back
row
okay moving on um the second priority
area to focus on is making rough
sleeping rare brief and
non-recurring Rapid intervention and
prevention methods have significantly
reduced rough sleeping in our districts
particularly for new cases and those at
risk however addressing long-term rough
sleepers with complex needs requires a
more tailored approach involving support
for mental health drug and alcohol
dependencies and institutional
experiences in terms of achievements we
have already insured contact is made
with all rough sleepers within 24 hours
of getting a referral we have accessed
funding streams when available for
additional support to tackle rough
sleeping following the initial
successful rough sleeper initiative bid
in
2019 we have participated in multi-
agency panels to manage Monitor and find
Housing Solutions for the hardest to
house clients
we have procured 19 specialist bed
spaces where rough sleepers are
accommodated including Street to step
beds transitional beds and move on
units we've also provided suitable
accommodation for rough sleepers in
extreme weather conditions under the
severe weather emergency
provision we have provided regular
Outreach work to those individuals who
have disengaged from services to
facilitate ongoing
support we have supported service users
in settled and move on accommodation to
sustain their
tencies we've procured the services of
beam to work with service users who have
been marginalized from work training and
education to provide opportunities to
get back into an emplo
employment and next we will be focusing
on training for staff to identify root
causes of recurring rough sleeping and
unstable housing histories for rough
sleepers with complex needs using person
centered trauma informed interview
techniques we will be engaging multiple
agencies through co-production and Joint
protocols to provide intensive support
including mental health NHS Outreach
teams and Drug and Alcohol
Services we'll be contributing to Cross
County co-production work with Campbell
tickle Consultants to establish a
multi-district approach to Service
delivery commissioned by the suffk
housing board and we'll be forward
planning for the ending of rough sleeper
initiative funding in 20125 including
team structure and continuation of
Service
delivery
thank you Rebecca
questions councelor
grandon thank you chair can I ask um
what kind of accommodation you obviously
this is quite a sort of difficult um
part of the mix and um they need or may
need a certain amount of additional care
to which you've referred what kind of
accommodation do generally um refer
these um people to um during covid quite
a lot of people went into hotels and
that kind of thing but I presume they're
not hotels now and you talk about
longterm um accommodation or are they
hotels that we can stay in for a long
time could you perhaps um
elucidate um so the sleeping initiative
funding provided us with money to um use
properties we have step beds so we have
Street to step beds um where people who
are rly been going to those step beds
initially and they that mean sorry they
can be a room in a house of multiple
occupation or we also have some
self-contained and then we keep
um individuals there to we assess their
needs and then we look at a transitional
bed which will be a longer term bed once
again we have room rooms in houses of M
multiple occupation we also have bed
seits we have one bed flat so it sort of
depends on the assessment of that
person's needs and then we have longer
term accommodation where we will provide
support and we provide support all the
way through that journey and we also try
and get in other Services mental health
drugs and alcohol
GPS um health professionals to just make
sure we can help sustain Tendencies
moving forward when people move on from
our rough sleeping pathway so it's quite
a long pathway we have lots of different
accommodation depending some people
really Thrive by being in a house and
sharing with people you know other
residents really don't want that so we
have to be quite person centered when we
do that first approach that sounds very
good because obviously um they would all
have different or may all have different
needs and it's quite an
intensive um kind of help that could be
needed and need a lot of intervention
sometimes we struggle to to to to get
people in off of the streets because
they're really they're really scared
they're really nervous they've been
through the system so many times they
don't trust us um it's really hard so
sometimes it can take months during
covid during the everyone in time we had
a gentleman that had been sleeping rough
for three years and we have finally we
got him in during the everyone in we've
worked with him he's now rehoused he's a
he a he's a a pension age an older man
and all those she sleeping rough and now
we've got him in and that was intense
long work you over over over a period of
of years to get him to that position but
that that's what we need to do we need
to change those ways of people may I ask
another question please please
do
um I I think um we we tend to think of
our district as
being not having too much of a problem
so I don't know whether that's due to
your good intervention
or um that we we're just not aware where
do do they tend to be in our main towns
or could you give a little bit of a I
can a picture of of this place we we
would look at Rough sleepers as um we
have incidental R rough sleepers so we
have people that sort of come through
our district or people who have had a
relationship breakdown fallen out of
work and they're people that we can tend
to move on quite quickly and then we
have the other more entrenched rough
sleepers
um so the incidental ones tend to be in
our town areas Market towns the r the
entrenched very rural and I you know we
have been out we have found people with
tents in Hedges and in fields that we
would not have known about and you know
the officers will Patrol areas we have
Street link that inform us if there's
sighting public can get hold of us to
say you know we've seen a tent um the
entrenched people are the are the
individuals that we have most difficulty
with getting them in because they are
they have their setup we had a gentleman
who was in a car park he was um in his
80s and he'd been in a car park sleeping
for months and months and he just didn't
want to come in he'd had a change of
circumstances and he you know I'm here
I'm safe I know where I am but for for
us that's that's that's untenable for
him long term but we needed to convince
him that coming with us he could trust
us and would make the right decisions
with him so it's um I I would urge you
all to come out with the rough sleeper
team if you if you have some time it's
very interesting work and and you get to
speak to the service users as well who
will feed into the strategy because
they're the ones that we we base the
strategy on you know where are the
barriers where are the obstacles what
can we do to get over those tell us you
know because we can't make a strategy
write a strategy without people's input
I've been hearing that quite a lot of
people in this position find themselves
sleeping in cars y does that come under
this
rough yeah absolutely absolutely um and
Caravans um camper van as well we look
at that it's all it's all rough sleeping
not rough sleeping they're not on the
streets but it but it's housing that
can't be um what's the word Elma
sustained sustained thank you so you
know we did the rough sleeping count
last week um those results have not been
published yet um and we had but I can
tell you here we had three people in
subury and one person in Stow market and
they were all people that we knew people
that we were working with and trying to
pull in so we had no new rough sleepers
that was really that's a really good
result withough four Town sounds
terrible it's a very good result we knew
where they were um and it was a targeted
approach on that night to to see them
but nobody else so it is very
interesting you're welcome to come out
with this thank you that's really
interesting very helpful thank
you counc scar I think thank you chair
um my question is sort of the forward
planning after the rough sleeper
initiative funding finishes in 2025 um
I'm not exactly certain how much money
we got as joint councils for that um but
obviously there's some financial
implications for us going forward and a
commitment therefore in the lack of if
there is no more uh initiative funding
available from central government how
how how how are you going to plan for
that because that's quite a considerable
funding income stream to provide the
service and we've expanded the service
in order to meet that so it's how do you
stop us going off a cliff face in
2025 I'll pick this one up I think it's
something that I'm quite conscious about
because we have a whole team structure
around that providing that service for
our residents who are asleeping
so I suppose for me the the question is
is how do we keep the same level of
service so it's about looking at what we
do the systems we have in place you know
the terms of how many offices are we
going to need what can we afford to
deliver I think that's what it's going
to come down to is what can we afford to
deliver to maintain this level of
service to make sure that it doesn't
fall backwards and we end up with people
rough sleeping on the streets where we
can't meet their needs
so I suppose this is something that
we've always know that's going to come
because we don't know if there's going
to be any further funding in
2025 um so it will be looking at
restructuring the team the service and
what does that mean where do they sit
you know and what that structure looks
like we're not quite sure yet but it has
to be something that fits within our
envelope of what we can afford within
the existing um housing solution service
so that's what we'll be looking to and
it for me it's always about value for
money and also about making sure
whatever we deliver is sustainable going
forward so that's definitely a
consideration so I think what we're
having to look at is the whole service
because it's R sleeping has got this
extra special funding additional funding
but for me R sleeping is homelessness
it's a part seven application everyone
is making so it's how do we make sure
that that particular cohort still gets
the additional support they need given
their complex needs and as viicky has
said the amount of Officer time is going
to require because you usually don't get
them off the streets the first time
round it's going to take time and what
does that look like so we're going to
obviously have to look at our numbers of
the r that we're helping what's happened
with the RSI funding in terms of what
did we do the numbers that we saw what
does that mean in terms of case load for
officers and actually
what what does delivery look like
because it's going to look different and
that's something that we're quite aware
of in aun to so it's not going to be the
same it we might go down to two offices
I don't know right now but those are
things that we're generally having
consideration now and planning for and
seeing what that looks like and what
that cost to deliver and how that works
across the both
districts councilor SCA asked exactly
the same
question all right councelor
Carter I think Vicky wants to add to it
as well could I
thank you councelor Carter thank you
councelor Carter I just wanted to say
that when the rough sleeper initiative
when we went for the funding back in
2019 so much has changed so
theoretically by 2025 we should have
solved Our rough sleeping problem um
clearly we're not going to and nobody is
going to because things have changed
with the pandemic and the cost of living
so I think you duu they're going to have
to start thinking you know well they
must be thinking now it's probably a
plan now about what we're going to do um
because it we have reduced it we have
made it a better Journey we haven't
eradicated it as we as we really wanted
to so thank you thank
you um thank you um having in a former
life having spent some time on the
street and being homeless at home I can
say that the improvements we have made
are astounding so thank you for that and
I would really like to take you up on
your offer to go go with the team
sometime um I would say in the in the
report there's a case study about a
gentleman with his
dog and I do know that for certain rough
sleepers they will not engage us out of
fear because they will be separated from
their animals and I wanted to check what
engagement are we having with those uh
and when we're talking about beds and
these houses what is happening to their
animals because it's like a it is a safe
is a crutch a safety it's not just say
when you separate somebody from a it's
like a a Lifeline so what what agencies
are working with for the animals are we
working with something like a Street Vet
like we have in London and what happens
to if they have a dog or a cat um are
they housed with them or are we looked
after in temporary cation or how goes
there thank
you I was going I can pass you over to
Michaela who's our temper accommodation
manager to answer that one thanks
Mick hi I'm Michaela I manage the
temporary accommodation for bab mids um
we've sort of been developing a pet
policy where we take it on a caseby
casee basis there's a lot of people now
who have emotional support animals and
they are registered so we have to really
be aware of that you know in considering
people's disabilities and need for their
pets we actually do permit pets into
some of our temporary accommodation
where we can facilitate that because we
recognize how important those pets are
to people especially those facing
homelessness um so yeah something that
we are working on to keep pets with with
their owners and it is in it's in our
policy that we will try to facilitate
that where possible we also have to be
really mindful of risk though if we're
in sort of HMO type accommodation shared
accommodation
um especially I don't want to mention
but we have had you know EXL bullies and
you know large dogs in our accommodation
as well so that's a big concern because
then they POS could pose a risk to other
residents and staff so we do really have
to be mindful when we're looking at
people's situations which we have to do
on a case- by case sort of
basis can I go in again councelor Carter
please because if if we can't
accommodate for whatever reason reason
it is in our homelessness code of
guidance that we will look at what we
can do to provide other accommodations
so there have been times when we've paid
for kennels or ceries for animals when
people can't afford it or we've looked
at payment plans um around things like
that we would also do that if it came to
Veterinary Care um if somebody couldn't
afford it we could look at sort of
repayment plans or working with local
vets to to enable that to be easier for
people to access so yeah we're very
we're very open to animals but as Mick
said sometimes we you know you could
have a whole house with a lot of
different animals in there which could
be very hard to manage so but yes we are
mindful of
that have you got another question
coun all right
okay thank you very much chair um you
said that we won't hit the um the
targets that we' set before because of
um covid and the cost of living crisis
um looking into this we it seems like
ever such a lot of things are going
badly wrong at the moment like lack of
rental properties rental prices through
the roof the we're a um rural location
which doesn't really suit the benefits
system we've got um discretionary um we
got local housing
allowance that isn't moving any where
and we're propping it up with um the
discretionary housing payment um are we
going into crisis with this or are we
just going to miss our figures by a
little bit or is is this going badly
wrong thank you I'll answer that
question I think I think everyone has
this really
ambitious Target of ending rough
sleeping I come from the point of view
is that you can't end it because people
are rough sleeping for a number of
myriad of reasons you know so I think it
it's it's making it rare and brief and
non recurring is the real Croc of the
matter so that we don't end up with ENT
entrenched rough sleepers I
think I think generally in terms of the
whole Countrywide experience there is a
crisis in terms of all the different
things happening at the same time which
doesn't help if you have one thing
happen then yes yes you try and mitigate
against that but I think it's really
difficult when you are combating
against elect local housing allowance
rates which are not where we need them
to be to help us to help people to
access the private rting sector because
I think it has to be recognized that the
private rting sector is a tenure of
choice for some residents and we we need
to make sure that we try and maintain
that which is why we have Central sofic
lettings um so that we can enable access
to that I think
it's I think for us the context of B mid
suff is
that we're managing the situation you
know we'll always try and be really
Innovative and we always try and sort of
horizon scan of what could the issues be
what's cropping up which is why we we
have a data analy within Housing
Solutions which we look at the trends in
terms of why are people approaching what
are the reasons so that helps us focus
on do we need to be focusing more on
these types of situations and look at
what's happening and how we mitigate
against that which is why we have the
early prevention team to sort of of I
want us to change the behavior as our
residents in terms of coming to us as
early as possible which is why we have
the online to Tool advice Adria they can
go and have a look at their look at
their situation go get a little bit of
housing advice to understand what their
situation is because in these types of
situations people often come to us when
the problem is a lot bigger and if it
come to us when say you were1 worth of
rent or you were feeling like I'm
struggling and I can't afford this at
the moment is there help out there for
me cuz earlier and the more Upstream you
are with the prevention the cheaper it
is actually you know if you come to me
and your rent you're you're in fear of
affordability we can deal with that but
if you come to me and you've got £6,000
worth of rent of is it's a different
type of solution that you're looking at
so it's a part of educating residents in
terms of if you have a problem you come
and get housing advice from your local
Authority which tends not to be what
people do at the moment we're the last
we're sort of the last place they come
to for advice and it's often in my
experience being the case that oh if
you'd come earlier we could have cleared
your1 worth of rent ofers we could have
a negotiation with your landlord to see
how we can put things in place we could
have talked to benefits to look at you
know maximizing your income so we could
have done all those things so I think
it's us about making people and
residents aware that we're here and
that's what we're for it's almost as if
like someone thinks about buying a house
they'll go talk to their bank so I
really want us to be in the position
where if our residents think
I want a little bit of housing advice
regardless of tenure because we're
tenure neutral I might go talk to my
local Authority and get some advice from
them so that's where we're hoping to be
the direction of travel because it's
always about your planning and
preparation and how you give people the
tools in order to navigate because
there's always going to be some sort of
Crisis and some sort of issue but if
people have given the correct tools to
understand okay I'm in this situation oh
I can get dhb I can go talk to my local
Authority am I on the right amount of
benefits what other options are there
out there for me I'm on a zero hours
contract and this is really affecting my
ability to afford stuff are there
training courses I could go on what's
out there so I think there's a lot of
different things that we could be doing
to support our residents and actually
it's about empowering them to have the
tools in order to deal with the
situations they come up against so I
think that's the thing that we can do
because no matter what happens there's
going to be a crisis of some sort
there's going to be some issues and we
just need to give people the tools
in order to sort of help themselves with
us there supporting
them you want me to say about the
summit councelor gron I'll come to other
counselors when the committee have
finished asking
questions thank you chairman um on page
27 of our report you list um the numbers
of units of temporary accommodation that
um that we have available in our
districts um are those units owned by
the district or are they
um private
accommodation and also are they
sufficient um do they tend to be
sufficient I'm sure it fluctuates but uh
generally is that sufficient numbers for
the needs in our districts or do you
sometimes have to go outside our
districts for for such
accommodation most all most of the stock
is owned by us they're our owned
properties we've got a few that we've
taken from housing associations and I
think there's one from a chch United
Reformed Church um we do um sometimes
have to use Hotel accommodation but that
all tends to be within our districts I
don't think we go outside of our
districts at all really rarely so it's
they tend to be in our districts I
mean we have a strategy to House people
who are in priority need regardless of
the numbers so whatever happens if we
have to sour alternative accommodation
that is what we will do we always try
and keep people within our districts if
that can be the case I mean there there
are Peaks and troughs there are times
when we've got a little of give within
the system and then there are times
where we could be struggling depending
on the demands on the service and what's
happening so you can never have enough
temporary accommodation ever I challenge
anyone on that but we're always looking
at how we can use our current stock you
know if we get properties back from
housing relating support we will look
can we use that for additional units of
temporary accommodation going forward so
we're constantly looking at how we our
demand and then what the supply is
likely to be we Michaela and the team
are always quite clear about the
pressures what's going on and
negotiating good rates as well if we
have to go to external providers but
majority of the properties we have on
our temp compation are from our own
stock and is the demand
seasonal it depends not as much as it
used to yeah it used to be you could
tell when if people if you had the major
holiday summer holidays Easter Christmas
used to be quite quiet not so bad and
then anything between it would Peak but
right now what we're experiencing is the
demand is quite high at the moment you
know there have been points we have run
out of 10 three accommodation but we
will find some more accommodation
because that's our job you know our job
is to accommodate people and our job is
to make sure we've got enough placements
to place people unfortunately that could
mean that we might have to sh commercial
hotels in a very short period of time
but then we'd look to move them on to
Alternative temporary combination thank
you very
much thank you any more questions from
the councilor Mar and I'll come after
Cal councelor malvy but are there any
more questions from the committee before
go to visiting
counselors no
councelor I'm um it's not quite a
question it's more a question and an
observation because I'm coming to this
as the mental health Champion for babber
District Council um and counselor um
Terrence Carter raises some very valid
issues with um pertaining to dogs being
pets Etc because for rough
sleepers a dog represents
safety because that animal will
protect the rough
sleeper um and to claim that you're
going to end rough sleeping I feel is
unrealistic It's a Wonderful
ideal but unless we remove the factors
that
actually make
people become or go homeless and the
biggest one is sexual abuse abuse
violence and mental ill
health um so you the council is in
effect
providing a safety net for those people
um but I'm sure that most of the people
you find sleeping under Hedges will be
men and not
women yeah well that was my experience
in Scotland absolutely I mean firstly
eradicating rough sleeping wasn't our
idea that was the department of leveling
up they told us we were going to
eradicate rough sleeping um by 2025 we
probably quite possibly we we have done
very well as districts um to be fair
um we like to think that we can signpost
and wrap
support um to Our rough sleepers because
we're difficult we we're not supporting
our hous and and it is very difficult we
we don't see many women rough sleeping
if we do they are potentially you know
the most vulnerable people and and
harder to work with as well once you
lose that trust
um so yes we we don't think we will ever
eradicate it however that's that's what
we need to try I have got an answer for
you councelor b as well about the
domestic
abuse do you want me to say it now might
just as well I can do I thought it might
interesting for everybody so out um so
in bab District Council out of 593
applications so far from April the 1st
and 41 of those stated domestic abuse as
their Prime reason for being
homelessness now we do often have it
counted as a second thing as well so
somebody might have um had a notice on
their private property and then they've
disclosed to us that they they did
suffer domestic abuse But but so that's
18.2 2% no sorry 15.47% in
bber are domestic abuse as the first
reason and in mids suffer it's
18.22% so so not dissimilar
really it is RA it is rising all the
time in my in my experience over the
years I've been doing this for over 20
years it is getting worse and that's
about people
disclosing you know that we've got um
different rotes for people to be able to
tell us disclose issues seek support the
judicial system the police systems it's
it's just easier for people to talk
about domestic abuse and I see that as a
Rise um in the main instance and of
course we have to look at things like
the cost of living housing crisis and
and other Global um crisis as well
that's going to affect people's
relationship so there's lots of lots of
things in there the Dara accreditation
would be really worthwhile I think it's
something that districts and bers are
doing Nationwide to to try and make sure
we're all doing the same thing for
people I hope that's
helped councelor mson thank you chair um
yeah I I was struck by councelor
caston's question particularly um you
know whether we we're kind of heading
into a really difficult time um with the
mortgage rate increasing what a year or
so ago now um there's there's sort of
nationally reported that um that
landlords small scale landlords are are
selling up and um you know and this is
are we seeing additional um no fault
evictions um for that
reason and if we
are um seeing that locally you know
actually happening um are we
considering possibility of actually
buying properties in order to uh avoid
the the tenant being evicted so that the
landlord can
sell we don't buy I think I'll address
the first part then I'll hand over to
Steph Central lettings I mean we
currently we do get approaches from
private landlords sometimes to see if we
can buy and acquire the units but it
will it will have to be look at it if
it's viable for us to do so because
there's also the is aspect about
maintaining the property when it comes
into our stock that will be an issue but
we try and see how we can negotiate with
the landlord in terms of keeping the
tenant in for as long as possible buying
isn't something that's really been part
of our plans per se but it would it
would depend on the circumstances of
that individual
but it would we would have to look at
the H business plan in terms of what is
in the budget in terms of
Acquisitions um and it has to be
affordable it has to make sense you know
so yeah but I'll hand over to Steph
who's better place all right Stephanie
Lloyd's um team manager for Central
stings um we've got a portfolio of about
100 private rental properties um and we
have seen a really small percentage of
landlords sort of leaving our scheme to
sell very small I think maybe we've had
one to actually sell we've had someone
else who has increased the rent because
if their mortgage rate has gone up um
our our kind of stock retention is
usually quite good we're able to offer
like a fiveyear plan so which has been
fine when landlords have if they're
mortgaged if they've got a longer term
rate so we can offer some security um to
sort of mitigate that problem but we
have we have seen a bit of a impact um
we have seen some movement and most of
our stock are landlords you have between
one and five properties as is the
largest percentage in the in the UK
stock anyway so we are predicting that
we may we may lose
some is that it councelor maon thank you
can I oh councelor
Carter apologies a question I had
occurred to me before come back to me
regarding the stock that we have I've
mentioned regarding pets but what um for
the um the beds were uh what portion of
stock do we have that is accessible for
those actually may be have a Mobility
issu or um my own experience was when I
was waiting there I was told that there
wasn't any accommodation for myself to
be when I disabled uh well I am dis but
there wasn't any accomodation me and
that was a few years back have we
improved and got more accessible
stock we have improved councelor Carter
yes um it is quite bespoke we have um
three or four units in each district
that are um accessible and we've got
some units that have got flush for flat
um showers and different things for
different people's mobility issues or
disability issues we have got a new
property that's coming back to us it's
been leased at all well housing for
quite a number of years um in Hy it's
coming back to us and we are hoping to
make that um a unit of four flats that
are going to be accessible for all
disabilities so there's even a um a bath
in there that's that's fully
converted for people so we're just
working on that at the moment it's just
come back from Orwell housing and we're
looking plans to to do that so yes we
have improved I would still say we yeah
we we still struggle sometimes with
people with different disabilities and
we have to then look
at our stock and we do take things out
of stock we do make changes and use them
as temporary accommodation and then
sometimes we the people stay in those
Tendencies um we've done that quite
often so it's always a challenge I I
wouldn't say we're on top of it but we
are in a really positive position better
than we were five years ago
definitely thank you that it's brilliant
to hear really is um the final question
occurring to me um there are instances
where families find themselves um
or Partners find
themselves how is our policy for do we
try to house together or are there
instances where they have to be for any
reason how separate or uh what is the
ground grounds here if they are more
than one individual that needs to be
have a bed for or to be
roused I have we have never um housed
somebody in temp accommodation and split
the family
up
never um my experience was I wouldn't
house with my wife at the time but that
was going back quite some years ago okay
yeah not in my experience we haven't we
we've never split a up heavy because of
need disability needs no I yeah that
would be interesting actually get your
views on that outside this meeting thank
you thank you can I just remind
committee members that we're going
through each priority and questions
really need to be targeted at each
priority as it's on the screen however
Rebecca you're getting a lot of other
questions that are outside each priority
do you want to complete your
presentation and then because you've got
five priorities haven't
you what what would you like to
do yes I think it's a good idea Council
McLaren we'll finish the presentation
and then we'll have and then questions
at the end I've noticed that the
questions are actually way out the
priority we've got on the screen and I
want you to be able to advise members as
much as possible so would you like to
continue
Rebecca thank you okay moving on to the
third area of focus which is ensuring
the health and well-being needs of
households are met whilst in temporary
accommodation um this strategy is
focused on preventing homelessness and
minimizing the use of temporary
accommodation however if temporary
accommodation can't be avoided then we
are committed to ensuring a positive
health and well-being journey and
avoiding contributing to homelessness
trauma efforts are underway to enhance
the entire tempor accommodation
experience offering more signed posting
and multi- agency engagement
the focus is on implementing measures to
mitigate the impact on children's
education health and
socialization in terms of achievements
we have already established four tempor
accommodation Refuge sites where we
provide ready to move in furnished
properties with food Parcels children's
toys and books household items kitchen
utensils and new
bedding we've secured 12 units of
temporary accommodation with Sanctuary
housing which also provide a higher
level of support for single people
we've appointed a secondary settlement
officer to focus on enabling households
in temporary accommodation to be
actively looking for housing
opportunities maximizing incomes and
ensuring households are tenancy
ready we've procured the services of
beam which is a homeless social
Enterprise to assist marginalized
service users into employment Education
and
Training in the coming year we'll be
introducing a minimum standard of
temporary accommodation for children
including provision of sterilizing
equipment child and baby equipment such
as stairgates and age appropriate books
and
toys we'll be providing pre-tenancy
training for all households in temporary
accommodation and a pilot pilot of this
started on the 26th of September this
year we'll be ensuring Wi-Fi and
internet access is available at each
site with accompanying digital skills
training from the cost of living
team we'll be exploring setting up a
notification system which ensures that
at the point of household registers as
home
relevant existing services are informed
such as Education Health and Social
care we'll also be working on
implementing a project of planned work
and upgrades on All Temporary
accommodation making adaptions to new to
a new temporary accommodation unit to
create adapted rooms which are
wheelchair
accessible we'll be working on
destigmatizing temporary accommodation
and homelessness by sharing experiences
in a realistic and respectful way
ensuring that we are not reinforcing
helpful attitudes and
stereotypes we will also be adding
testimonials from households and virtual
tours and reviews of temporary
accommodation filmed with tenants onto
our
website and we'll also be working on
improving our temporary accommodation
green spaces and encouraging gardening
interaction from residents to assist
with Improvement improving General
Health and
well-being okay priority four um which
is expanding and future proofing the
role and remit of central suff lettings
to continue to improve access to the
private rented
sector expanding resident access to the
private rented sector Cuts Reliance on
bread and breakfast accommodation and
eases the burden on temporary
accommodation shifting housing duties to
the private sector can expediate finding
new homes diversify housing options and
preserve social housing for those in
urgent
need the central surf the central suffer
leting Service established in Spring of
20 is dedicated to cultivating enduring
relationships with landlords and letting
agents and providing diverse quality
affordable and secure tendencies in the
private rented
sector in terms of achievements we have
already cemented Central suff lettings
as a well established brand with an
online presence and a growing portfolio
of
properties we've carried out a survey of
landlords to inform direction for the
service we've negotiated houses of
multiple occupation through work with
landlords to meet the needs of under 35s
who are limited in the private sector by
local housing allowance rates Central
suff lettings now has a three bed house
in multiple occupation in Stow Market in
its
portfolio we've also collaborated with
the empty homes team and landlords to
bring properties back into use through
the Central Central suff leting
schemes in the next year we'll build on
this work and will be further promoting
Central suff lettings to extend its
reach including to let boards and
targeted
advertising we'll be raising the profile
of central suff lettings within bab and
midu District councils by linking in
with economic development and planning
um to provide an offer at the start of
Housing
Development we will be acting on the
results of the recent survey of
landlords including considering
extending the current landlords package
or delivering an extended
service we'll be providing pre-tenancy
training in conjunction with the stone
foundation to contribute to maintaining
tendencies returning tendencies in a
better condition decreasing antisocial
behavior and preventing
homelessness we'll also be focusing on
creating a new website and increasing on
our online presence expanding the HMO
portfolio um building on the empty homes
project including more publicity
communication and an offer to landlords
to work with us we'll also be um
focusing on being an active part of the
landlords Forum in partnership with safe
suffer
renters we'll be procuring a new tency
management system to support the growing
business we'll also be considering a
charge to landlords who come onto the
scheme as this could generate an income
for bab and with suff district councils
and will be quantifying the cost-saving
value of central suff lettings to B and
mids District
councils okay so this is the fifth and
final priority area um which is
mitigating against the cost of
living Rising fuel food and essential
costs in conjunction with existing
vulnerabilities amplifying the risk of
immediate hardship and reduced
well-being for many households and this
is disproportionately affecting some
communities this prompted bab and mids
District councils to launch a fivepoint
action plan in May
2022 this cost of living plan is
regularly reviewed due to uncertainties
global challenges Market volatility
inflation and dynamic shifts in
household
budgets housing costs to the strain for
many households and are exacerbated by
stagnant local housing allowance rates
and increased mortgage interest rates
all of this converges to heighten
concerns about Rising homelessness in
The
District in terms of what's already been
achieved we've sent targeted
Communications to Temporary
accommodation tenants and bab mids
tenants to highlight advice and help
available and to encourage accessing
support
earlier we've updated our web web pages
to ensure that residents can be sign
posted effectively to other agencies for
advice and
support we've established the household
support Grant which is funded by central
government for households to apply to if
they're struggling to pay rent or
service
charges we've introduced an inter
internal referral form between ourselves
and mid suffk citizens advice to speed
up the referral process and to get help
quickly to those who need
it we've also continue to work closely
with the Department of work and pensions
and citizens advice to tackle the
impacts of welfare reforms in the roll
out of Universal
Credit we've monitored repayment
agreements and the number of evictions
for renters to consider the success of
our budgeting advice and affordability
checks so we can help clients to manage
their income
effectively we've launched a fuel
poverty toolkit for Frontline members of
staff to
use we've administered winter warmth
grants for Community spaces and we've
mapped all the food banks operating in
the districts and shared this
information next year we'll be focusing
on using data mapping to look at
deprivation in the district
district and using this intelligence to
pinpoint areas for further targeted
communication and early intervention
work we'll be building stronger links
with the communities and rents teams to
target areas where collaborative working
would bring benefits for residents
including using rent sense data to
Target where help is
needed be taking part in a pilot with
angryan water to ensure social tariffs
are more easily accessible and will be
taking part in the development of a f
food security plan for suffk alongside
Community Action
suff we'll also be introducing an
internal referal referral form between
babber um citizens and advice and bab
mid suff District Council to speed up
the referral process and get help
quickly to those who need it we'll be
continuing with targeted communication
campaigns as in when required to ensure
residents are kept well informed and
will be signposting to appropriate
low-income tariffs when households move
from temporary to permanent
accommodation and just in ter terms of
what will be happening with the draft
strategy from here and its journey to
endorsement and
adoption there'll be a period of public
consultation running from Monday the 4th
of December to Sunday the 14th of
January during this time there'll be an
all member briefing sessions for all
members to ask further questions the
feedback gathered from consultation will
be evaluated amendments if necessary
will then be made to the strategy and
the strategy will go to Council meetings
in March for final approval and
adoption
thank you
Rebecca councelor grandon
first thank you madam chairman um this
is going back to your priority
four um you stated that one of the
things that you were planning to do was
considering a charge to
landlords um to to come on to the scheme
um can you tell me what your thinking
behind this is when there's a shortage
of landlords generally in the whole
sector me in private and um non-private
sector um and um you know what what what
you hope to achieve apart from some
income but why would they want to come
onto the scheme if you're going to
charge them when there's a shortage of
land la s it sort of seems a little bit
of a surprise that you might be
disincentivizing um people please could
you explain it y sure um I think there's
a lot there actually um I think if
you're a landlord and you've got
property to let you will need someone to
let that property out and if if you can
let it out for yourself if you want to
manage it yourself so you know you take
care of it there won't be any you won't
have to pay any fees but most landlords
will place their property with a letting
agent which we will cost them money so
for a landlord who's looking to let a
property out um they one of the most
thing one of the things they'll consider
the most would be who which agent is
offering the cheapest fees perhaps so
for us at the moment we offer a free
service and the service we offer is is
very good it's very comprehensive and
very similar to what you would get for a
a paid service so the charge that we
would be looking to introduce and that's
kind of like a three-step process
because there are things that have to
happen in between because we're Council
so we'd have to set ourselves up as a
social lettings agency um and you can
only charge a token amount we're not
about making a profit but what we're
about is trying to generate some Revenue
to help to to to pay for the service so
the the charge that we would make would
be very would be very low um we've did
on our recent landlord survey we kind of
split we put the question out there to
our landord to ask how much you would
pay for a service like ours so we have I
mean the figures that came came back
were you know we we only gave them sort
of small small amounts you know what
High Street agents May charge 18 20% of
the rent per month you know we we're
thinking of between 1 and 5% so it's
more um a CH a token charge to we do put
a lot of time resource and effort that
the amount of how we run the service in
terms of sort of what the man what the
land would get as a free service um
there's a lot of work that goes in is it
would be very I mean it's free at the
moment so it's very good value for money
at the moment but it would give it would
still give very very good value for
money for a landlord we
think I'll add to that and say I think
there are extra things that we have as
local Authority so because housing
standard sits within our service area so
in terms of making sure the properties
are meeting the right standards you know
in terms of the compliance that
landlords have to stick to they can get
advice from our housing standards team
so we can link them in so what we do I
think is slightly more than a lettings
agency in a sense because we have access
to the environmental health officers who
will go out and check a property and
provide advice to any landlords that
approach us for help and assistance and
want to join the scheme so that is
offered as well so there's lots of
things that we do I mean in terms of if
their tenant runs into renters because
it's rent guaranteed we pick that up but
then we will deal with antisocial
behavior issues we'll go out there we'll
deal with that pulling the servic that
are required so the things they don't
even have to think about that we will
pick up and do which they may not
probably get from a lesting agency per
se who would first instan is to go out
and evict the tenant where we were going
to work with somebody to make sure
that's sustainable and how can we work
it out and is this the right setting for
that individual because there are times
where that's not the appropriate setting
so we work as a whole system service in
terms of talking to Choice based
settings and is there an appro more
appropriate setting for this individual
rather than this placement so I think
what we offer is quite Superior to what
letting agents do and Steph's team does
an absolutely fabulous job at that as
well can I can I just add to that so I I
sort of assumed that you knew what the
service offer was because um there are
as as Amma
said in in this package that the
landlord gets so you would you would
weigh up if it's worth the charge that
you're paying so the landord does get
guaranteed rent so if if a tenant moves
out there are no voids so that that that
period would be covered there is at the
moment a cash incentive for the C for a
landlord that joins the scheme so you
could offset any sort of lower amount
that you would take each month in rent
with with the cash incentive all of the
teny management is covered so you would
get the inventory the routine
inspections repair coordination right
through to checkout um you wouldn't
incur rental re should the tenant get
into rental and we we can't resolve that
with them then unfortunately would would
be the council that takes the the risk
the hit so some landlords that we have
on our scheme that works financially
better for them than letting it through
an agent and paying a little bit more
but it's horses for
courses thank you I understand it much
better now thank
you councelor
Jameson thank you chair um as I
understand it um some of our temporary
housing units have a mix of talent
um they'll have families alongside
people with a history of antisocial
behavior and drug use and I wonder what
sort of support we're giving to people
in that situation are we are we
providing a lot of warden visits could
we provide
more I I'll ask Mick to to answer that I
mean we we try not to mix anymore like
like we used to in times um in the past
we did um M thank you so I'm really
pleased to say that for most of our
family accommodation it is
self-contained we rarely Place families
in in units or sharing facilities only
an absolute
emergency uh and then that we will be
looking to move that person or that
household onto self-contained as soon as
possible um generally our our single
people perhaps who
have uh mental health or drug or alcohol
are sort of accommodated in our HMO so
our rooms where they're sharing
facilities and we have a lot more of a
staff presence now thanks to our team
which has grown
so we also we also provide some services
from a security um firm as well that do
drive around to our temporary
accommodation in the night um as well to
just make sure that everything's okay
and also because we provide
accommodation for individuals fleeing
domestic abuse so we want people to feel
safe as well so we do use that service
okay it's just from my understanding
there are issues at places in Sudbury
for example where there is mix of
tencies so is obviously still happening
I'm just wonder what we if we're aware
of that where would that be c
um can't remember off the top of my head
but um I can find out for
you yes yeah it would be good to know so
we have sandam court um they are a
mixture of bed sits and one bed and two
bed Flats but they are all
self-contained we've got the Furs which
is a house of multiple occupation the
leaves which is the
same and we've got Warner place which is
run by Orwell and then we have some
separate little properties we call them
satellites which are our own stock
houses um but in those units we don't
have families in The Furs or the Lees do
we no we'll get some more details in and
come back to you do yeah please do okay
thanks
ccor
Smith thank you chair um my question is
about temporary accommodation as well um
to speed up the speed that people get
moved on from temporary accommodation
are they placing band a in the um when
when they moved
on um so the system is uh is complex so
when we accommodate somebody into tempor
accommodation
um we then assess their homeless
application so the banding is based on
their homeless application and then
other factors go into that so band B is
an accepted homelessness case we also
have a band B options which is something
at the beginning of the journey um that
we know is going to be an accepted case
at the end we do have options to award
bandaid um we look at exceptional
circumstances we look at the makeup of
that family and any needs that they've
got within that household and we make
that decision and we we go to a panel in
the Gateway team um to look at that and
consider it would be lovely to have
everybody in ter got accommodation on a
Banda a and move people on quickly
however we've got the rest of the of the
housing register who also have some
massive needs we've got people in
accommodation in our general needs stock
that need to be moved for medical
reasons and they're a bandaid so we've
got all of those factors it's very hard
but we can do we can look at that as an
option and we do we get information from
social workers GPS about households that
particularly do um meet the criteria for
our high band and then we we assess it
all so we can
do thank you thank you councelor Casten
thank you chair um to deliver the
strategy we need help from Partners um
who are the most important Partners in
that and um how do will we need to
consider the funding of those Partners
or assist assistance with
funding sorry about the
question what would we like is what
you're
saying we we always it's always nice to
have more funding I think the partners
we need to be working with more closer
is probably mental health because that's
what we see that's most the need need is
for I think it's also about making sure
that sometimes it's not always about
money it's about how effectively we work
and collaborate with our partners to
make sure that when you're dealing with
households we all have the same
information we're working together
rather than sort of sometimes butting
heads or working against each other
tends to be the situation because
actually we all have the ultimate same
goal is to assist someone to help them
from being stopping them from being
homeless or getting them out of temp
accommodation to Perman accommodation
that's suitable for their needs so I
suppose for me in to deliver the service
some of the things I think for me one of
the most one of the important things
that we do is the tency sustainment
financial inclusion work that we do
because that's 10e blind for all our
residents and I think in a situation
where we are facing cost living crisis
where more and more people are
struggling whether you own your own home
or whether you're renting having a Tenon
neutral tency sustainment Financial
inclusion service which is free at the
point delivery where people can come in
obviously working really well with our
partners in citizens of advice so that
we work across the piece support
residents in these times it's it's one
of the things I think that's really
underpinning it I that's from my
perspective I don't know if Sarah and
and Susanna have any they want to
contribute to that in terms of what
they're seeing from their end of the
spectrum sorry
s and so on I'm part of the early
intervention team and we are seeing
obviously a lot more people coming
through from mental health we are seeing
um landlords serve a notice um so yeah
it's just increasing and I I would also
say that we we're seeing people coming
through from supported housing scheme so
the supported housing providers cannot
deal with the level of need that those
people have being placed with and that's
really really sad a few years ago we had
some schemes that had higher levels of
support they are now being drawn back so
they're only offering low to medium
levels of support and it's just not good
enough so we're getting people being
evicted from supported housing and
coming to us and we can't meet their
need however they've been they've been
evicted from the place that should be
able to meet their need and that's
that's a massive issue for us really
massive um you know that Council Carter
don't you it's you know it's horrendous
and that's and that's really sad for for
our residents as well that we C you know
we can't provide completely what they
need and neither now can housing but
that's a whole another ball game isn't
it go on do yeah press
button sorry need do this um so um we've
been working on a case at the moment so
a lot of people obviously we come
through the homelessness route um but
there are other routes into helping
people and I think in the early
intervention team that's what we're
trying to do like there is another route
that you can come in and you're still
going to get the same result but maybe
not through the homelessness R got a
particular case that's come from Social
Services the lady hasn't got capacity um
and which is obviously very highly
documented um so she hasn't got the
capacity to make a homelessness
application so even though we can't help
her through the homelesses route there
is another route that we can take which
is through the housing register so
that's what we're trying to work and we
work with our partners on that and
there's a lot of meetings but it is
sometimes hard to get um Social Services
aware that there it isn't just
homelessness there is another Big Rob
Brader rout and that's obviously that
what we do in the only intervention team
is trying to prevent that person coming
through a homelesses room which
technically they can't do so trying to
work look at all the options and that's
what we
do
Wyman thank you chair uh followup point
to councelor gon's question on Central
uh suffect lettings um when we first
talked about this a few weeks ago I was
really quite surprised at the the
business itself but also compelling
offer that it that it has um what's our
plan to extend the you know the the
profile of Central suff lettings and
have you
considered some of the real pinch points
of where we get sort of penalized with
private rents tends to be in the more
rural communities where there's a
different sort of financial driver for
for lettings have we considered like
some kind of public private partnership
with with farmers and and the state
owners that have property that are
likely sorry less likely to release that
property simply because it's not
probably in A1 A1 condition and a second
question under under priority five um
for for tenants in um particularly
single tenants in private accommodation
the angling water issue on tariffs is
really quite a big problem because
you'll often find in older properties
again uh angling water are less inclined
or can't fit meters which means they
revert back to the to the ratable value
which means you can have a single person
paying you know 4050 pounds a month for
their for their water charges so it's
it's a you know it's a really good point
and I think that's a real problem with
um with rental
properties yeah I can answer a little
bit of that if if you if You' like um
with regards to sort of access and and
pitching out to people that have
multiple land and property like the the
the farm industry that you mentioned I
know I know of sort of quite a a large
portfolio holder um over on the
peninsula way with with a lot of
properties um yes would' love to get out
there and and have them all on our books
you know we' do it tomorrow I think it's
for us as a council in some we limited
to a degree in terms of budget for
publicity and marketing so sometimes
it's difficult to do a widespread
approach that perhaps a high Street
letting agent could
do sometimes people or landlords may not
think of the council is eff first
thought for lettings we have and that
that will come in with our work we do
around working with other departments at
the council like Economic Development
planning so it's about raising our
corporate profile really because we have
the links out there but it's we're here
at the bottom so it's making sure that
the rest of the council are you know
what why why are we building all of
these houses and why are you not giving
some to Central stff at lettings to let
out you know we we need to get our
profile raised corporately um so that we
can have that Avenue so we can because
as we know stock is diminishing in the
private rent sector um there's 5 million
people that live in the private rented
sector in the UK we have no choice we
have we have to and we should be working
with the private rented sector we should
have an offer for the private rented
sector we have a good offer we're
reputable we're not going anywhere with
the council so for a business and a
landlord we do offer some security it's
just about how how do we pitch to them I
can pitch to them but I kind of need the
corporate support and the business
support to to know where they are and
how to do it and I think we've
established ourself now I never like to
like pitch or launch a scheme when we're
not proved so I didn't want to launch it
we we launched in covid which was like a
crazy time to launch but now we're sort
of three years in and we've got a team
and you know we we know our success and
we know our failings it's a much better
time to take a stronger offer to to the
market um and with regards to the water
question um we we have that a lot with
because we've got a tent support officer
who goes out to our portfolio properties
um there's a lot of support particularly
at the moment for help with utility
costs for people who are on prepaid
meters um there's lots of grants that
come through agencies such as iron
Services about insulation windows so
there are help for landlords a lot of
landlords are not even aware of the
support but lots of the because we're
out there so much in our tensies we can
pick up on points like that so our tent
support officer would sort of pick up on
issues certainly like that for our
Tendencies and be able to help sort them
out I think and and speak to anglan
water
directly so just want to add to what
saying one of the things I'm quite Keen
for us to do is to consider turning
Central s lettings into either a
community interest Community benefit
type
organization so that we're an ethical
lettings agency that would allows
because at the moment as a local
Authority we can't Grant tendencies that
aren't secure and that tends to be one
of the stumbling blocks for us in a
sense about what we do with Central St
at lettings going forward so we are
exploring the options of could we become
a community benefit could we become a
community interest company where it's
your non for-profit and you're working
for the community but we're also
widening the access into um private
sector renting I have worked on other
local authorities that have done a
community benefit companies where they
have bought properties but then that all
depends on your sit
circumstances as well and what your
business plan is so we're exploring the
options of going forward what does that
look like so that we can be not
necessarily a little bit more commercial
but have more flexibility and
adaptability within the market and look
at what sort of offer that we offer out
to um residents to landlords as a whole
because I I'm quite Keen for us to
explore the idea of having intermediate
Market rents because everyone's at
different levels you know and everyone
needs different access to different
types of accommodation I know that we
have issues within suffk attracting say
workers into the NHS is there something
that we could provide a product out
there in terms of rental units so
there's lots of things that we could be
doing to leverage on that so we we're
defin looking at that as part of that
whole priority as what happens what do
we do and what do we
offer members I've got three counselors
booked in to ask a question at the end
of those three I'm going to draw the
questions to a close we've had a very
long session uh and I'll explain what
we're going to do after that so the next
one is counselor Smith thank you thank
you um the the report mentions empty
homes uh coming back into use and the
houses for homes that was launched
earlier this year I just wondered if
there's been any success with
that
yet we have had some success with that I
can send you information about what's
been happening we have managed to bring
some properties back into use um
properties definitely be identified
having two offices as opposed to one as
we've previously had has made a vast
amount of difference in terms of our
reach and definitely working with
landlords in terms of owners what they
do to bring their properties back into
use helps reduce issues around ASB
making the communities nicer as well if
the home is not being kept up to date
but we can provide you information
they've done actually a really good
report in terms of where they are now
and what they've done so we can share
that if you'd like as
well
yeah councelor
grandon thank you
um I've had um situations in my world
where um people who have had mental
health concerns have been placed in um
our housing
and um have sort of
caused Great upset and concern to other
residents near them their neighbors
um now I can see that it's a very
difficult situation from everyone's
point of view but um I wonder if there's
a better solution and and what in in an
ideal world what would you like to do um
in that kind of
situation
and if if there is an ideal world are we
anywhere on the way to achieving that
because you know I've had at least two
situations um where it's caused very
great difficulties um um where that's
concerned thank
you I I think it is really difficult
because sometimes we have people in our
temp accommodation for quite a while and
they manage really well and they Thrive
and then we think they're ready for move
on and there have been times where
people have been placed in a in
permanent accommodation within our own
where we thought it was going to work
and it would be fine it's a good setting
cuz sometimes you're not going to know
until someone goes in but we we do try
and make sure there is support on hand
in terms of support for the individual
to help them to manage the tency but
sometimes you are not going to know what
those issues are going to be because you
don't actually know how people are going
to react to each other and sometimes
that's what it boils down to so you'll
find that we we have seen those resents
where we have placed them in different
settings it hasn't worked and then we've
gone a third time and actually it's
worked remarkably well with the
community they've been placing to and it
unfortunately sometimes it's a bit of um
trial and error because you're not going
to know how something's going to work
out because there are times where you
played someone you think this may not
work it might not be ideal and it's
ended up working really well we think
we've had some people go into Tendencies
where they thrived you know become a
really engaging part of the community
you know the mental health is being
managed effectively and it's been a
great setting for them so there there
are instances where we're not successful
and and that is with everything in life
but we always try to try and manage that
situation effectively as much as we can
and there will always be that input in
terms of how do we sustain that tendency
if we can because that's always the
first Port call what things can we do in
order to make it successful but then
there will be periods of times when we
look at the situation we've done
everything we possibly can do to make it
work and it might not be we have to look
at the impact on the individual that's
in that teny as well as the other
tenants around the and and balance that
quite effectively and then we will make
decisions of whether or not okay
depending on the circumstances and that
particular case we might take that
person out of the property and then look
at how we can then look at what the next
best placement is for them I think the
issue is as Vicki alluded to in terms of
the housing related support it's not
people are being evicted from there
because it's not working effectively and
we have a lot more residents of quite
number of high needs that need to be
managed effectively General needs we
would always say is not always the best
place for people with high needs because
some people just need to be in supported
housing High support and they need that
intensive management
so soorry it's just incredibly difficult
because if the resource is not there
then we have to try and do the best we
can with the resources that we do have
to hand so that is a lot of trial and
error sometimes unfortunately is like
you look when we allocate something
officers do look at where they're being
placed look at that individual we talk
to Michaela's team how they managed in
temporary accommodation so sometimes I
think the temp accommodations the
officers do lots of visits don't they so
they go out quite regular they build a
rapport the individual people become
really well versed in their location and
it and it settles them but I think it's
that transition period and not knowing
what happens when you do that permanent
placement because you place people and
it goes ably well and it's good great
for them and their surrounding neighbors
and sometimes people get a placement and
it doesn't work and it breaks down and
as long as we make sure that we have
processes in place to deal with what
happens when it breaks down how we can
pick things up how we manage that
effectively that is probably the best
that we can offer giving the current
resources can I just say counc Grand I I
I know who you who you're talking about
and I know that that person was told
that their needs were too high for
supported housing and yet they weren't
high enough to have a social worker so
we were stuck between a terrible rock in
a hard place of where this person fits
in I mean you and I know that person
needs social care
intervention um so it's a real shame so
there there are some some areas that we
really need to work better with
different services or they need to be
better working with us so I do
appreciate your point thank
you and the final question from
councelor Jameson thank you thank you um
do you feel that um single men tend to
be disadvantaged when it comes to
rehoming I mean possibly understandably
but is there anything we can do if they
are did you stop them getting left
behind I I don't think that they're
disadvantage in our system no at all
because our system is if if you are have
a priority near under homelessness we
can pick you up into our temporary
accommodation and take a hom application
if you're a rough
sleeper um we also look at picking you
up or putting you down the rough sleeper
Roo so I don't think that they are
disadvantaged as per the you know the
myth that has been in the past however
we do see more single males becoming
homeless than we do single
females I think I'll add to that and say
I think pre H the house homelessness
reduction act there wasn't much of an
offer for the singles that tends to be S
single men with the way the legislation
is structured we have a duty to prevent
that doesn't look at priority need that
actually looks at within those 56 days
how do we prevent you from being
homeless whether you're male female
whatever we're there to pick you up so
that has actually resolved that issue of
if you were a man you know fit healthy
you were literally told to go away and
sort yourself out we now you know we do
personal housing plans I got uh housing
solution officer that will work with us
um so they're part of the process
they're not forgotten about now with the
changeing legislation it focuses our
minds on preventing and it you're not as
an officer you should not be thinking of
if someone's intentionally homeless you
know if they're in pridey because that's
not what you're looking at the what
you're looking at at prevention stage is
are you threatening homelessness within
56 days and are you eligible that's it
so for me my expectational officers is
you pick up a case how do I stop this
individual from becoming homeless what
can I do with them within the next 5 to6
days work together you know how do we
find them accommodation what the other
barriers they're facing so I would agree
with Vicki that since
2018 that should not be the case anymore
that there we have a statute of Duty
know that makes it really clear about
what we should be focused on and doing
within that first 5 to six days when
they're threatened with
homelessness can I just add to your
point quickly sorry I know we're in a
rush on that point I I think with the
under 35 particularly single male group
that we see I don't think it's um I
think we have the L we don't have the
stock out there to suit that client
group so we don't have many one beds
affordable or shared that that's the
problem which probably perhaps you're
thinking that there's more single or
more single men out there is because
there's not the property to suit them
especially in the private rental sector
I mean and you know hmos are really good
for that they can be really affordable
but you know it's an aspiration should
be an aspiration for everyone to want to
have self-contained not everybody wants
shared so I think in our district as bab
and mid we do lack sort of the property
to suit single single people that's
that's a big issue in I I find in the
private rent sector
anyway we've come to the end of the
questions um
members before we go to debate I'm going
to call a five minute
break because midu have
got
yeah I need a
gble welcome back members after that uh
short
break well we finished a very long
session of questions which I think
members found really
helpful and uh so we now go into debate
who would like to start the debate
councelor Piper would you
yeah um can I just say I think the
Housing Solutions team do a fantastic
job
uh with um I've initially um I mean have
some have had some experience over the
past few months uh with the Ukrainian
family we were hosting and the work they
did in getting them temporary
accommodation was
fantastic uh they really pulled out the
stops so yeah I think they do a
fantastic job and whatever we can do uh
to improve what they can do would be a
be a really good thing I
think scar yes thank you chair I'd like
to Echo that I think um the depth and
the breadth of the work that the team
have presented this morning is truly
tremendous so much information there for
members um coming around perhaps to what
we might consider for an extra
recommendation to move things on a
little bit um I think we need to uh
support very strongly um the domestic
abuse housing Alliance
accreditation uh and I accept that that
that is has some costs and a lot of work
associated with it but I think if we
support that very strongly we are in a
much better position should there be any
further future Government funding for
rough sleeping initiatives because there
may well be um and I think we'll be
judged on based on what we've delivered
over that period of time and that's an
incredibly important part of it um and
also uh we heard about the resources
required the financial
implications when the rough sleeper
initiative funding ends in 202 2 and I
think that really is a very serious
issue um because I would hate to think
that we actually have to tailor our
offer based on more limited Financial
Resources otherwise we lose all the
benefits that we've achieved with the
team over all that working o over that
period of time so um a strong
recommendation perhaps just to cabinet
that we are aware of that situation and
we expect cabinet to be preparing for
over for the coming years the ending of
that Financial uh support from central
government on the basis that we have to
prepare for the ending of it even if
there may well be another round that we
could bid
into thank you
chair thank you very much I completely
agree with the two um recommendations um
councilor scarf put in there I think
they're they're fantastic I think this
is a really good piece of work it's
amazing like the amount of work that's
going on it's um it covers a lot of the
um the cases where it's really
interesting to see what's actually going
on and how much the team are doing I'm
still really worried about the this
going forward um homelessness in mids
and babber because the the the districts
have changed so much since 2019 it's
shocking I I was here in 2019 and it was
a a completely different environment for
it um I think um one of the things
that really stood out is it's almost
impossible to do the um that really
early prevention if people won't come to
you if you can't find the people that um
that need need that help and um getting
in there before like the county court
judgments and all the things that step
in the way of um people that aren't easy
to put right is really really difficult
the um it occurred to me um that maybe
we could advertise what we do more maybe
we could have a campaign on buses in
supermarkets saying look this is this is
what we do we we're here to help and
it's not just for people that have to
leave their property it's for people
that they know that every month they've
got more going out than coming in and
that it's not not sustainable and I
think that would be a really really
great thing for the council to do to
just get in there early because that
saves US money as well um when we do
that the other thing we talked about
under
35s on here and how difficult it is to
help them and um there's another issue
with this and it's the under 25s the
young people that don't get the same
benefits are still cost them the same to
live in a house but they don't have the
um they don't have the benefits they end
up sofa surfing and in really unhappy
situations where they have to stay
because they've got nowhere else to go
and I think we we maybe going forward do
need to look a little bit more into
under 25s as well as the under 35
because it the it does change a bit with
the um with the um you know under 25s
and in the next 10 years but um yeah I
for me I think this is this is really
good I think it's the situation that's
happening in the districts that worries
me not not this um not the work that's
been done because that's fantastic but
thank you very much were you suggesting
councelor Casten that we um I don't know
whether we do this but I I would support
any letter to um the uh cor the
corporate manager and her team for the
the work they do and the the
comprehensive report I mean I think it
was a very comprehensive report would
would we be happy to do something like
that is separate we don't normally do it
but it was a very and they work very
hard is that what you were suggesting
well I'm quite happy to put that to the
committee and for people to that's
that's up to everybody yeah to leave
that and also we've got court failure
holders and officers in the room that
that are listening so um yeah thank you
I think it's out of we don't normally do
it but
um one has to be impressed with what the
team were doing and that early
intervention has actually been
beneficial to uh I work with rough
sleepers and um I mean it's very hard
work and very intensive and very
comprehensive but I'd be happy to uh
accept that as
a I'm not sure it's a recommendation but
we could give it to
to execute we yeah thank
you thank you chair I was particularly
impressed with the central suff
lettings part of the business that we we
operate and I really strongly believe
that we have a such a great offering and
it will allow us to by improving the
profile of central Civic lettings it
will give us the opportunity to bring
that into the strategy of the council as
a whole such that we start to look at
the way we plan uh in the countryside
you know part of our part of the jlp
part two potentially so that we can
release and create more uh ability to
build flats and or you know single
two-bedroom kind of properties uh and
working almost in like a public private
partnership with with land owners and
and and with property owners because you
know I think we're sort of hiding what
is a really gem underneath underneath a
stone to some extent and anybody who is
a private land will know the challenges
of you know getting people in getting
people out dealing with all the issues
and also more to the point letting firms
where we clearly we're doing an amazing
job so I'd like to think that we could
potentially enhance our reputation by
you know by building the profile but at
the same time build what we do into the
whole strategy of of the joint
councils thank you any more comments
from Members oh sorry
um thank you um as I said previously
this is night and day compared to what
I've experienced and I can't commend the
work enough what has been done um this
is certainly negated C some of the fears
and stigmas that I was under
previously um I'd like to Second a
proposals and the comments made from uh
from my colleagues the other side of the
room because you've all picks up on
things that we do and we need to work on
especially coun caston's of fears and we
do need
to work on those um you mentioned
regarding the advertising on buses well
we can do more as placing advertisements
in areas that would be likely used for
shelter putting up um so like bike racks
can be are you is sometimes frequented
but put up tense um areas or things so
actually if we are
having um a certain day where we're
going to be holding these where people's
going to be available to have it
advertised for V
for not only it sort of um letting
people in that situation know that we
are thinking that we are going toward
even not going towards make even if I
don't make the steps themselves just to
know that we may be looking to help so
if it's just advertised and making it
reassurance especially in the media at
moments where the the talk has been the
media
regarding um lifestyle shows oyers thatl
it's become stigmatized it's become even
more ingrained in society and people are
fearing that we are trying to take
things away that we are trying to move
them on and it is something that we do
we need to work on towards reassuring to
build back some trust
so any all recommendations that we have
made today fully support and we can do
anything we can do if we can do more we
should uh so thank
you any more comments by committee
members
no right Alysia um do we need to deal
with coun Scar's recommendations first
because he propos well we didn't really
get proposal but we need a proposal and
a second for those before we put them in
any order do we need that first um
that's fine we would propose and vote on
block for them but I would I have
written
down um rough recommendations based on
what councilor scaf has said so I just
wanted to read them out just to make
sure that they uh make
sense before we go any further um so I
have the cabinet explores further
methods of me to the domestic abuse
housing Alliance
accreditation is that roughly what you
were talking about with your first
recommendation sorry yeah strong strong
support from this joint committee for
the accreditation process that's fine
and um the second recommendation from
yourself is that cabinet makes Ser plans
to provide financial support for the
services provided under the strategy
beyond the end of the off sleeper
initiative funding in
2025 sorry I um it's fine um so those
were the two um recommendations from
councilor scar but I do have three more
recommendations based on what was said
by other committee members if you'd like
me to read order them okay um so
recommendation one is that the overview
and discution committee commends the
housing department for the work that
they are conducting to help eradicate
homelessness in the districts and
requests that officers take on board the
comments made at this
meeting uh number two which is a
recommendation that's being pulled out
of the report which says that the um
overview and scrutiny committee supports
R vision and priorities of a draft
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy and ensures that the
delivery plan is reflective of the
current challenges facing s the
districts um I have recommendation three
which is for one about the domestic
abuse housing Alliance accreditation
which is just read out uh recommendation
for that cabinet makes further plans to
provide financial support for the
services at the end of the rough sleeve
per initiative funding in
2025 and I also have as recommendation
five councelor caston's point which is
um that cavet explores further means to
providing assistance to those under 25
with getting onto the housing ladder in
order to avoid an influx of young people
becoming
homeless councilor
Carter uh just regarding the
recommendation one um on the comments
made by our housing officers and also by
could we maybe look at altering the
language rather than eradicating home
rough sleeping which does seem to be a
bit of
a yeah thank you actually I support that
counselor
Carter sounds like a game of
whacka
um right is everybody happy with what
Alysia could I just um I did say about
um them considering um more allocation
of resources towards promoting the
services that the housing team do to um
for early prevention to try and help get
the word out that that's what we're
there to do and we can do it long before
things you have to leave your home I
don't know if um obviously I've said
that in the meeting and be taken on
board but I don't know if we want to
have a recommendation that we look into
to how we can um advertise and promote
those and what we would need like budget
wise to um to deal with extra people
should there be
more Council wisman wman sorry may we
include an element of central suff
Latins into that overall Gambit of of
enhancing and improving um the awareness
of what we
do
yep that's absolutely fine if you give
me a minute to craft that into a
sentence that'll be
fine
um hang
on okay so using those points I have
written down um that cabinet explores
providing more resources to the housing
department to assist with
communicating about the services
available from both the councils and
Central suff lettings to those who are
or are at risk of becoming
homeless yeah that's perfect thank
you okay so we now have six
recommendations recommendation one that
the overview and scrutiny committee
commends the housing department for the
work that they are under that they are
conducting to help reduce homelessness
in the districts and requests that
officers take on board the comments made
at the
meeting recommendation two that the
overview in scrutiny committee supports
the vision and priorities of the draft
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy and ensures that the
delivery plan is reflective of the
current challenges facing the districts
recommendation three that the
overviewing and scrutiny committee
strongly supports the work being
undertaken to meet the domestic abuse
housing Alliance
accreditation recommendation four the
cabinet makes further plans to provide
financial support for the services
provided under the strategy beyond the
end of a rough sleeper initiative
funding in
2025 uh recommendation five that cabinet
explores further means of providing
assistance to those under 25 with
getting onto the housing ladder in order
to avoid an influx of young people
people becoming homeless a
recommendation six at cabinet explores
providing more resources to the housing
department to assist with communicating
about the services that are available
from both for councils and Central suff
lettings to those who are or are at risk
of becoming
homeless thank you
chair just can I have a proposal please
sorry just one thing by housing ladder
are we um talking about buying a
property or getting a because I'm I'm
not quite sure whether the housing
ladder means owning a property and then
that that recommendation wouldn't be
quite what I'm trying to
say well uh it would depend what you do
want it to say so could we change it to
adequate adequately housed to get
adequately housed sorry I don't I'm
struggling to say it but because I think
housing ladder suggests people with a
lot more um opportunity to
you get a roof over their heads than
we're talking about that's fine yeah
recommendation five would Now read that
cabinet explores further means of
providing assistance to those under 25
with becoming adequately housed in order
to avoid an influx of young people
becoming homeless that's
fine so councelor Jameson you're going
to propose the recommendations can I
have a second thank you councelor
scar
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress on Modern
gov
thank you chair members that is 11 votes
for so that is
unanimous thank you
Alysia so we now go to
item8 which is J stroke 23 stroke
28 overview and scrutiny Committee
Action tracker do any members have
comments to make on
that Jameson yeah um just it's on the
um
sewage um reference it seems to be lot
not started yet some with Target dates
of October just wonder what was
happening
there um I'm just looking at them on the
action tracking
now one of them says not started when it
should say complete to be honest um two
of them do which is my fault completely
um the that is in relation to 1.2 and
1.6 um in regards to 1.4 and 1.5 that
are not
started um I will take that away and see
if we can get some action going on that
because they really should be started by
now because it was about two months ago
now so that's fine I'll take them away
outside of a meeting and see what we can
do
page 109
please um and the third item down is a
review of the cast a review the current
costs of the West sa Community safety
partnership and Madam chairman thank you
for your uh email on this and I I accept
that we're going to have things in the
next annual review report um can I
suggest that we add to one point
free when this report might be
expected so you know so we know the
ongoing means something's happening
rather than it's fallen into the globber
globber that's uh that's fine councilor
Riley I can't add that to the actual
recommendation but what I will do is in
that progress column I will add that it
will be coming back to um in the next
annual report and the chairs will keep
on top of make sure the officers are
aware that that information needs to be
in there and we will be holding them to
that recommendation in the next annual
report um as I say I can't add it to a
recommendation that's already been voted
on but I'll add it into the progress
section just to keep an ey okay thank
you similarly if you go down to item
3.3 um the offic be requested to
undertake an annual
[Music]
survey um if the surveys is only take
place till March then I can understand
them you know sitting around for a
couple of months on the other hand if
there's no
um deadline on this it'll sit around
forever and be
ongoing um is it possible you I'm quite
happy the officers to you know give us a
suggestion as to when this um annual
survey will be done and
completed yep so from recollection that
was meant to be implemented at some
point in this financial year um and that
was essentially um almost an endorsement
of what officers were already going to
be doing anyway but I um so my process
after each committee meeting is I
contact the key officers that are listed
in the column um and I asked an update
on all the recommendations that still
outstanding um it's it's the chief
planning officer that is related to that
item so I will have a discussion with
him as to whether that survey has been
put in place
yet and provide you with an update so if
you then turn over to uh page
110 um items
3.45 six and
seven again you know all ongoing I say
whenever I I I've been at committees
where I ra queries I've been told it's
ongoing and it's a device to shut me up
it doesn't mean anything whereas if we
have a a time on this don't we know that
something is being done or it's being
thought
about thank
you looking at the dates on that Alysia
that was pre this
committee what I will suggest coun Riley
that the chairs and vice chairs together
will just look at some of these items
that are quite
longstanding and we can come back to the
committee with our findings can't we do
you agree with that
James yeah I think so um I think um
maybe some of these red not started ones
need to be sent straight to Cabinet as
well and so that the we need to do
something proactive about you should get
a list every cabinet meeting of what
we're still waiting for
okay no that's fine I take those
comments on board we are sort of behind
the scenes now trying to put together
some like some better processes for
getting these recommendations through to
Cabinet to make sure they're seen in a
timely manner and something is done
about our recommendations and that falls
under the uh cabinet scrutiny protocol
that got approved this time last year um
so there is um procedure in place to
help push those through we're just going
to try and give them an extra nudge
which is what we're working on on behind
the scenes myself and uh the monitoring
officer councilor Riley is that
acceptable to
you so members please note that the
overview and scrutiny action track is
only for no and we will take up any
discussion we've had and the chairs will
discuss that
this concludes the business of this
meeting
at
133 can I thank everybody for coming oh
can